[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maintenant qu'ils gagnent tout cette
relation là et je changeais le compromis
ça n'existe plus à washington si les
gens sont même étonnés
entre temps tout a été mise en place
pour assurer une transition en douceur
en france les autorités évoquent un
attentat à nice et si le message aussi
que très rapidement été lancé et rentrez
chez vous ne restez pas sur place c'est
qu'un véhicule a foncé dans la foule il
y aurait des victimes selon les témoins
les autorités qui ont évoqué un attentat
la belgique est sous le choc dans le
moment c'est le plan catastrophe qui a
été déployé à l'intérieur de l'aéroport
de bruxelles deux kamikazes ont fait
exploser leurs valises au milieu de la
foule une heure plus tard une autre
explosion dans une rame de métro il
bil'in ici est encore plus lourd
en attendant que bruxelles se relève
petit à petit les critiques commencent à
pleuvoir sur les autorités belges
ils ont réussi à protéger le
centre-ville est probablement dix mille
résidences qui ont été épargnées par les
flammes
l'évacuation de 80 mille personnes s'est
faite sans victimes
jean lapierre commentateurs politiques
que bien connu ils se trouvaient à bord
de cet avion qui s'est écrasé dans le
secteur havre aux maisons ont rappelé
est évidemment donc la carrière de jean
lapierre qui est le grand homme qui est
extrêmement connue au québec
l'epl amap épreuve constitue en quelque
sorte un instantané qui révèle à
l'ampleur et l'efficacité des structures
secrète pour échapper au fisc
ainsi que la facilité avec laquelle les
bien nantis peuvent y accéder
un des fondateurs du cabinet marsac
fonseca nie avoir quoi que ce soit à se
reprocher vous avez eu de dommages tout
ce qu'on fait dans la vie on le fait
pour être aimé moi en tout cas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je m'endors
rené angélil c'est quelqu'un qui me
faisait sentir comme était seul aux mots
lorsqu'il parlait à quelqu'un je pense à
céline le vide que maintenant autour
d'elle c'était quelqu'un de plus grand
que nature
[Musique]
on